have you heard of New Coke like the
1980s and Coca-Cola is losing market
share to their rival Pepsi people like
Pepsi because it like is sweeter so they
did something kind of crazy they changed
their formula their big secret formula
they changed it to make it more sweet
they did a bunch of like corporate
research and it came back and it was
like yeah people like this more more
than Pepsi and more than regular Coke we
gave America choice and more people said
Coke is
so in 1985 they tell the world that they
are releasing this new formula and
because people are people they lost
their Collective about it their
little protest groups our children will
never know refreshment so yeah there was
huge backlash and after just 79 days
Coca-Cola announced that they were
bringing back the old Coke and it would
be called Coca-Cola classic so that
everyone knew this wasn't New Coke and
lo and behold Coca-Cola started
overtaking Pepsi again to become the
most popular sugary drink in the world
congratulations Coca-Cola I kind of am
curious what new Coke tastes like but
I'll guess I'll never know